Dear viewers,
first of all, a warm welcome to
all of you here in the hall and
to you in the online live stream. There
is also information for you
that we are able to
achieve good interaction here,
including via the digital channels. I am
very pleased to see you  to this session this
morning and yes a
few words about me my name is Felix
Runde I am not a
scientist myself but I worked for years
in science communication
as part of an agency that
takes care of strategy and communication for science organizations and
I would like to share  The panels today share a
passion
for solutions to
climate change in biodiversity and yes, I
have been closely involved with the Balance Science Week here for a long time,
which is why I am even more pleased that
I can lead you all through this
morning -
they already have the title  Recognized it's
about water as the elixir of life in
cities in the climate and
biodiversity crisis and our
object of study today is also in the
room. I took the liberty of
bringing what exactly that is about.
I'll briefly
explain it again in a moment. In any case, it's about water
Cities are about the major
challenges in this complex for
us humans for cities for
nature it is of course about global
warming quite explicitly and about the
mass loss of biodiversity
in this country too but it is also about
perspectives and hopeful solutions
that of course come from this
interdisciplinary  Viewing from the
different lenses that we also have
in science, in research, in
urban development, in management
can lead to seeds and that is
also represented here by our fantastic panel.
I will introduce our panelists to
you in a moment, so we have
planned some time for a conversation
Here, which deals with the questions that
I just mentioned, we have reserved time for
a blog for you and for your questions,
this concerns you as the
audience in the room, but as I already
said, the online audience, take a look
at the chat and  Feel free to ask
your questions during the conversation, collect them
and we will address them later.
At 12 p.m. we will
end the session here and then invite you
all to a network aperitif,
which is Swiss for
a little something to eat and something to
drink and you can chat,
which then takes place right here in the anteroom.
What I also have to say is
that this event is of course
a
cooperation between the
Humboldt University of Berlin and the
University of Zurich as part of the Bellen Science Weg  and that is based
on a strategic partnership
back meets Berlin, which
is of course very influential in
this year's science path, so
on behalf of the two institutions,
I would like to extend a warm welcome. Before I can introduce you to
our fantastic
panelists, I have
the pleasure of two  I would like to
welcome special personalities who will
address us with a few opening words
and I would like to start
with Johannes Vogel, our host
today, he is the general director of
the Museum of Natural History in Berlin and
he is a professor of biodiversity
and public science  everything is
exactly his body and stomach issues
and is also the president of the European
Citizen Science Association. I think
that's enough with titles. All that's
missing is to say that he is one of the
most important voices, for me too, a
really inspiring voice for
nature, that's the slogan of the museum and
just light the topic is certainly very close to our
hearts today we have a microphone here
Johannes stage is yours please here at the front
into the light yes yes yes very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very very big of of
thanks, welcome to the
Museum of Natural History the
Leibniz Institute for Biodiversity and
Evolution Research yes I am now
Director here for eleven years. Previously, I even did
real research for half a year at the
great University of Zurich in the Botanical
Garden. Now I'm identifying myself here.
Sex life on farms was
my specialty back then. Don't ask me
about it. No, now it's about why
they are  actually here in the house and a
warm welcome also to the great
panel and like ambassadors why this
house we are a research institution
here are 200 researchers in the house
about ten eight percent of the area
we have you can see the
rest is full of laboratories and collections
and these  Collections that are hidden like
natural history museums
and no one has access to them
because we as scientists
have to carry our knowledge within us and
we wear the title of professor and the
coats that we wear as protective shields
or perhaps as force vests
and this  prevents what we
believe is important from being
heard by anyone and if you
look at the newspapers now they
are now really pumping up the volume,
listen to what is now being
said about
threat scenarios, you know what the
effect of the communication is
Threat scenarios are
especially on the topic of climate, you know what the
consumption is increasing, more CO2 is
produced through personal consumption,
always think about what effects you
want to achieve, think about it
from the end,
so now we have this collection of 30
million objects here in the house
800,000
60 percent of them are young adults
between 16 and 40, a group that
no one reaches and they come here
and talk to us about the ideas about
sustainable living and democracy.
It takes about 12 years to have
such an awareness and such a culture in the
house  also in the visitors
that are three parliamentary
legislative periods
but if you are a mission-driven
organization you can tackle such things
and we have a really great
thing not only that I have a lot of
people in the house who
have strong communication and who know how to do
science  and horsepower on the street
but we also have objects
that allow different perspectives on the
world and on science
and I believe that science can learn a lot
from a place like this
because of the frustration
that we carry within us as
science-based people
People who think that we can't get our horsepower on
the streets is because we do
n't want to change ourselves. They
will only achieve change in others
if they change themselves
and science doesn't want that,
science can't do that and that's a really
big problem and that  Makes me very
angry about science,
the helplessness, the powerlessness but the
Pavlovian reflex goes on and on because
we're so used to it, it doesn't work that
well, but now let's go to the objects that
maybe talk about the subject of water, do they
even know where it comes from in
this world,
what should they say?  the water companies
I have ten percent 20 percent water
in my hand
4.5 billion years old
as old as the earth conterite the
bombardment of these asteroids and
meteorites on our earth has
ensured that we have water today that
is the gold with which they  can shine,
it's older than the earth,
yes, and then the matter of why
such boring collections in the first place,
this also speaks a lot to the
topic of what's up there, this strange, stupid
tube here.
Collections like this are well indexed and
digitized, you can see it below like
this  works are a
life insurance for us as
humanity,
they have been collected not
necessarily always for the purpose for which they
can be used today, they are
a machine that allows us to
answer questions that I have not yet
asked and this is one of
the examples  In
1859, in which Charles Darwin published the origin of
species, it was pulled out of the
dirt off South Greenland
and was sent to the Natural History Museum
Because the first
microbiologist Ehrenberg works here, he
describes the most important, the most
important, the most important, the largest,
quantitative, qualitatively largest objects
of the plankton that float on the surface
and ensure that we
can breathe, and then in the 1960s
these samples were used for
real ground-breaking research
which until recently
was most likely the most cited study in the world, namely based on
these samples and because these
samples were never collected,
evidence could be obtained
for the Milankovic cycles and thus the
evidence of natural climate change, so
what we do here is we keep these
collections accessible  We research
these collections, we open them up to
perspectives through society, through
business, through
science, in order to get to the questions
and the answers that
really move us. That's why we have these
objects that are not
collected for that reason, but we nevertheless have
a task to work on it  has been heard
by the Bundestag and the state of Berlin.
We have
received infinitely large sums of money to further develop this house as a place of dialogue
and science.
I would like to thank
everyone for that, but please help us all to
improve. Take a look at what is being
discussed here today  will look
at how the discussions are going on here in the house and
think about what you can do but
also what feedback you can give to us and the
others so that we can improve and get
the messages that are now being
said here onto the street
in order to help us all  To get out of
this not entirely easy situation,
I would like to thank you for a round of
applause, thank you very much, dear
Johannes Vogel,
the contributions that we ourselves as
citizens can make
will also
be a topic in our discussion today
But
now all the more warmly, dear Mr.
Ambassador Paul Seeger, he has been
the Swiss ambassador in Berlin since 2018
and of the many international stations,
I would only emphasize that he
was the permanent representative of Switzerland to the United Nations
in New York from 2010 to 15
International crisis
management I think he is particularly pleased today
about the
successful strategic partnership
between Zurich and Berlin Mr. Seeger,
it is my pleasure, thank you very much [
applause]
yes, good day everyone, I am
also very happy about this event today
what is the
elixir of life
for us diplomats says
that alcohol is somehow essential to our lives,
but I'll come back to that later.
You mentioned that
my last posting was in other places abroad
before I came to Berlin, which was Jan
Gón in Myanmar  and from time to time he
also has delegations that come from Myanmar
to Switzerland, the things wow
you can even drink the chlorinated water,
which is true but I
say I tried it here but as I said you can.
Water plays with us in Switzerland
I think in Germany there is also
an incredibly big role, not only
wastewater but also drinking water.
Here we also bathe in the fountains.
I'm from Basel, not
Zurich, I'm sorry,
but in Switzerland, bathing in
municipal fountains is quite common, and
that's sometimes surprising  People
abroad also go swimming in the rivers and see
who is bathing in our country. River bathing is
very popular here. I know people try
it here in the Spree with
some difficulty, but I can highly
recommend that, so that's the positive
aspects of water in the cities  That's
also negative aspects. I do
n't think we have to explain water in Germany.
For example,
climate change and water is a
big challenge for all of us,
especially in urban areas, and
in that respect I'm very, very happy
that there is this cooperation
between Switzerland  and Germany
but also especially between Zurich and
Berlin, I think there is this exchange of
behavior in some way between us, how we care for it, how we protect it, how
we protect
large waters together in the cities in
urban
environments, which I think is extremely important and
is also part of a very
peaceful and very fruitful one
Collaboration that we maintain with Germany
in general in the scientific sector,
we have several thousand
projects at the moment we have a
small problem with Horizon 2020 but
I won't come back to that but
our concern is very clear that we
want to continue to work with Germany with
Zurich with Zurich and Berlin but  I'm also
doing this research with Europe,
so I'm almost at the end. I'm
still asking. I'm saying at the beginning. I'm
still talking about the topic of fluidity and
diplomacy. I'm ending with
a quiz about what's
the difference between a
camel and a diplomat. I
can sift flour  Working days
without drinking, I would like to thank you
very much
[applause]
thank you for these opening words, now
I'm already putting you on the spot, I
know that the panel is ready, but I have to
briefly resolve this cliffhanger here again
and look at it  Samples, yes, I
learned from the best, you should always
have an object to show with you. We're talking about water in
cities today and we have water supply
here in the room.
I want to tell you briefly where it
comes from and why it fits so well. The prototo
for the debate is the one  we're
doing
this today I did it this morning with my
five-year-old son at Rummelsburger
Bucht, which is in the east of Berlin, where
I live nearby on the Stralau
Peninsula,
if you can put it that way,
a bit of dead plants, do
n't worry, no
biodiversity now  included here and
it is also led back into the
bay but if you stand there by the water and
look at the water and
turn in a circle then on
the one hand you will see buildings on the land side,
houses close to the water, a
promenade that is always used by joggers
Pedestrians, dogs, walkers in the summer it
is populated by
bathers, anglers, anglers,
they see lots of boats, they see peers,
they also see the surface is
partly built up and then
outside you see two beautiful
little islands, one is called Love Island,
very poetic, the other is called Katzbruch,
both in nature conservation zones  There are
even beavers, there are supposed to be otters,
but I've never seen them. Countless birds,
herons, cormorants,
boats everywhere, party boats in the summer. What
I mean by that is past pro toto.
This water is hotly contested
territory, if you want to put it that way,
or it's a
projection surface  for many
needs for many
necessities of life, of course also by
the nature of us people in need of relaxation
if we just put ourselves in this scene for a
moment and let it sink in for a moment,
we want to talk
about the various conflicts,
possible solutions,
adaptation options
and then we are finally
at the point where  I am not allowed to introduce him to our
wonderful finalists
and I would say I
always do it in pairs. We
start with two scientists, very
renowned scientists,
geographers, who we both also
work in leading positions at their universities, first of all
Michael Trappmann  from the University of
Zurich, the first geographer who is
particularly concerned with remote sensing,
that is, exploring from
space how biodiversity develops.
We have a few pictures
with us where we can talk about it. It is
of course about observing the development of
biodiversity on Earth
to measure other than distance, he is also the
founder of the World Biodiversity Forum,
a very important conference on the
topic and, by the way, he is also the
President of the University of Zurich. It's great
that you are there
[applause]
and of course you made the journey,
Mr. Christoph Schneider
is the next one here right next to Mr.
Freppmann from the Humboldt University
of Berlin also in geographer with a
focus on climate geography and with a
focus or a focus on the area of
urban climatology, that is, his team
develops scientific
recommendations strategies instead of
climate analyzes
climate change adaptation concepts for cities
also a very
important perspective for our conversation
today and here too he is also the
Vice President for Research at the HU Berlin.
Welcome
then we will continue with two
science experts who are
very strong in promoting new findings
but also, and that has to be said, they
communicate a lot  Planning and
communication with politicians
also contribute, I think, to the public agenda, I
think, can have a big influence on
climate change and biodiversity and
I'm talking about Verus camutione from the
University of Zurich and their research
primarily deals with climate risks
decision-making in
adaptation measures in climate change  and
that is an important role because they are also
in the sixth and most recent report of the
IPC, i.e. the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate Change on the
global state of
climate research. The main authors in the
Europe and Mountains chapter were really great
that they can be here
and whoever Ruska mozzone speaks
wonderful German but in these
Technical topics or these
content-related topics are of course
easier in English, which is why
she will answer the questions in
English. I think that's
wonderful. Sandra Jasper from the
Humboldt University in Berlin, yes her
research topics are primarily
urban nature  and especially
the human-animal-environmental relationship,
especially the social aspects of
these conflicts that we just
talked about. In her latest
research project, she examines the
many connections between health,
biodiversity and environmental pollution
and always with a focus on urban spaces,
which is interesting, maybe
we can  We'll get into that at some point. You're
also interested in
soundscapes, exactly the
sound characteristics of urban
ecosystems. Applause and a
warm welcome,
so we're moving towards the city
experts from the cities and
larger cities. First of all, Anna Schindler has also arrived from Zurich
Director of the City of Zurich Development
and yes, she is of course familiar with the
daily conflicts and challenges of
negotiating between the
many needs on the ground, which
is why it is extremely exciting
to hear her perspectives today. The NZZ has
written about her, the woman who
thinks about the Zurich of tomorrow  So
here too, a certain vision of the future
that I believe can be conveyed
and I think you have to say that with the
two city experts, they are very
much involved in communication in education
instead of nature, yes,
welcome Ms. Schindler
and finally we have Regina Kines here
she is the head of research and
development at the Berliner
Wasserbetriebe, she is
trained as an environmental engineer and has been
committed to clean and
natural waters in the Berlin area for years.
At the Berliner Wasserbetriebe,
she heads research and development. What is
probably not known to
most people is that the Berliners
Water companies are the largest water company
in all of Europe with
a supply of 3.6 million
inhabitants,
fantastic numbers for the
water companies, so they coordinate
research projects on various topics
along the water cycle so
[applause]
to overview here again
we'll show that again when they
then we would like to ask questions, we would
start the conversation and I
have already said that we want to look
at this topic from different perspectives.
The first perspective before
we then zoom in a bit into the
city is first of all the really big
global one, yes the big picture  What we
see here are
remote sensing images. I even have
a
false color with me so we can
switch between them. I would
first ask the question to Mr. Do
you then also write to Mr.
Schneider?
What do we see in these pictures? How do
we locate ourselves here in these pictures?
What makes the cities of Berlin
and Zurich special, especially when we
think about your water environments, thank you very much,
I think what you can
immediately see in these pictures is how
much we humans have reconfigured the earth and thus
also nature and life on
earth  For the benefit of
our society, you can see very
clearly that these are not natural
elements but rather man-made elements.
Both cities certainly have this in common.
What they also have in common is that
they still have a relatively high
green proportion, which means that
the water capacity is the
water holding capacity in both  Cities are
still reasonably
guaranteed
Mr. Schneider So if you compare the two
pictures you'll see pretty
quickly that Berlin is a bit bigger
than Zurich
because you can see the entire Zurich
city center but from Berlin
you can also see the city center
but if you look at it  If you want to see the importance of water
for the city of Berlin then
you have to zoom out further so that
you can also see the wall and the
Müggelsee and what you do
n't immediately see in the pictures -
nature is of course closer in Zurich
but the inner city area
of ​​Zurich  is much denser than
most parts of Berlin Berlin is
actually a pretty relaxed city for
such a large metropolis
and what you can't
immediately tell from the pictures is that
of course it's just in
Switzerland in Switzerland now there's a
bit more uphill  open downhill and
the water flows faster through the
city and that makes a huge
difference, yes we have one, we have
Lake Zurich here and then the
Limmat towards the Rhine and we have
the Spreewald and the Müggelsee in Berlin
and then we go along the Spree and
the  Harp together down towards Potsdam
but the way the water
flows through the city and the many canals
that Berlin has that Zurich
doesn't have is a huge
difference that makes the question of what significance the water
has in the city very
different  The two cities
then look like
before we talk about the importance of water
and also about the conflicts surrounding
water, let's stay
briefly in this big picture
analogy
and who rusker would really like to
ask
you when we look at the effects of
climate change  look at cities in general
now in global development,
what are the
characteristics of this, what can we
recognize to this day, thank you Felix
summerized understand so you my time
seen from the IPCC reported
one point one degree of any whales in in
the second part of the nineteen century
and this working President is for 2000
years for definitel
Region in Europe the same time is
experiencing increasing head waves
like experience extreme
yes that's a great keyword so where
all these effects come together I've
mentioned these conflicts of needs and we do
n't even have to go over them yet
Solutions or future strategies
first talk about such an assessment but rather
determining the status today, you would
go into what kind of
conflicts we find there, also in the
different areas. One is
water use for recreation, the
other is rainwater
biotopes Ms. Jasper, if you have that  So
also outline from your social perspective
what conflicts of needs
arise there. Yes, I would like to speak translated,
but I would perhaps
take you back to the past for a moment and throw two little ones at
Berlin, first of all, in the
1920s where we had a city planning officer
had the name of Martin Wagner who was
very committed to
providing access to viewing for
workers, including with the
expansion of transport systems and even back
then there were conflicts around the
privatization of viewing or the
preservation of viewing as places of leisure
was also a change at that time that
these spaces in the city
were integrated into the city, they see far away
and became places of leisure and relaxation
in the industrial metropolis, the
second highlight of Berlin in the
post-war period, the divided city, a
spotlight on West Berlin, a place that
was marked
The city
was built up very slowly through huge brownfields, derelict industrial sites, and as a result
the research field of
urban ecology developed. There were
very exciting studies carried out at the TU Berlin,
so a lot of knowledge about the
city's diversity was generated and
at the same time there was also activism from
the 70s onwards  For years there
has been a fight against large infrastructure projects, highway construction, etc. for the preservation of the wasteland, and we can still see that to
this day. Access to
water, access to the riparian zones
and the preservation of spaces for nature
are, so to speak, areas of conflict in the
city and the NABU  had a nice
headline from a few years ago,
free banks for beavers and citizens,
so we might see an umbrella, so to speak,
nature conservation and public
spaces, recreation, but at the same time it is
also an area of ​​conflict and exactly an
example in which we
can now experimentally observe how this is happening
This is, for example, the
Schuhmacher Quartier, the conversion of the
Tegel airport and the airport lake
next to it, a place that should have been designated
as a nature reserve for a long time,
the bathers
and how this constant
constellation of leisure use,
species protection, nature conservation and
urban development actually plays out.
Keyword urban development we have  Yes,
the real experts on the ground
here and I would also
ask specifically, using Zurich as an example, what
conflicts do you encounter in
everyday life but also in
strategic planning, thank you very much,
it goes in exactly the same direction, so
we have seen that, of course,
sometimes  smaller than Berlin but
Lake Zurich is then, together with the
rivers, a very important element for
the city and also for the nature
of the city plus we have 70% of our
drinking water is lake water and this
lake with climate change and
moderate use of both the
lake  like the rivers under pressure,
one thing is climate change, the
water temperature is rising. We also have
a project in the city of Zurich
called q-city with which you want to cool and warm
the entire city center with the lake in the
summer. That's also it
probably on the sea water
more of a stress factor and then we have
what you mentioned, we
also have a lot of conflicts or let's say
increasing conflicts in the area of
local recreation areas because that's what you
write, no, the ambassador has
already said that and for
you and ours  Rivers are seaside resorts, they are
really local recreational areas, they are somehow the heart
and lungs of this city and
they are being used more and more, so on
a beautiful summer day in Lake Zurich
you could almost talk about overuse
if you count the number of
motorboats on the lake.
We have the strategic answer  We
have a mission statement for the lake basin,
for example, we have
defined measures at the cantonal level.
In this mission statement we also have the
principle that the lake shore
is publicly accessible to everyone, but the
pressure is increasing and I think that is in
addition to the climate effects
So to speak, the human being is one of the big ones in the
conflict.
I would also ask you more questions about
the human being as one of the
conflict factors. They are also very
interested in the topic, yes,
education,
information for perhaps positive
behavioral changes, but besides that,
what else is there?  other factors
that you observe in Berlin, yes,
first of all, welcome, thank you very much
for the invitation and I was happy to
accept it. The first thing I think is important
is that Berliners and
visitors know that we have very
good drinking water here and that we can
actually use the water  They do
n't necessarily drink toilet water from the tap,
but that's
the value of the water. We can
also swim in Berlin, not on the
Museum Island, but otherwise in the
Spree in front of possible bathing spots in the Havel.
We also have an
early warning system because of course we do too
by reintroducing our purified wastewater into these surface waters,
this conflict about how clean the
water is, can we drink it?
Not only are we big,
but they also get their drinking water
from their own city.
Most people don't know that, which is why we
attach great importance to it. Berlin supplies itself
from the groundwater resource because we
have such good sandy soil, we have
a very good aquifer
good quality and we have to
protect that in order to achieve that, so
that the use of the
water is also there and when it comes to
recreational use we are of course also
dependent on the fact that there is adequate
use, no littering on the lakes,
the
quality that the infrastructure is also there
and  In this respect, this is simply an
important aspect. We have to restructure ourselves
as water companies.
Of course, it is very important to us that we
have a different use of rainwater. We have heard that,
on the one hand, we have the severe summer droughts and
heat, so there are still
statistics  that more people are
dying due to the heat, that means we are
really trying to create a cool and pleasant problematization through these
water areas through this green
infrastructure here,
so that
means water has a lot of importance
and I think we are already doing
quite well in that regard, to start with again  I would like to
throw in a really simple question and you would be welcome to
answer it like how it fits,
what is, why is it actually important to
have intact bilaterality in the city, so very simple but
you don't want Mr. Schneider.
The first thing I would say is everything
What helps the beer diversity in the city
actually also helps the
quality of life for the people in the
city, so that's not it, they're actually
almost exclusively win-win situations,
yes, those two, so what
's important from the city's perspective. Cities
are getting hot because of the energy  which comes into the
city from the sun cannot
go away via evaporation and
therefore has to heat the buildings and is
then released back into the air via the warm asphalt surfaces and
concrete parts etc.
That is what the
city produces much more heat at night
during the day because
this storage energy is
then released into the buildings at night, especially into the city,
and the best way to
get this under control is a well-
ventilated city and that means
a lot of green spaces, a lot of parks,
undeveloped areas where the air
can flow  it is well ventilated and
the second thing is as much vegetation as possible
because where there is intact vegetation there is
evaporation and then the energy
that we otherwise get into the urban
heat island goes
away into the surrounding area with the evaporated air and that is why it is important
we have as much green as possible in the city
and that means we
automatically have as much
beer diversity as possible, but that would also
ensure that in the summer, when there
are droughts and the heat
is particularly immense, that we
have enough water in the city so that
this vegetation also exists  what
can evaporate because a different lawn is
not much better than a concrete surface
there are already some really
important recommendations observations
from research will then
pause for a moment but once again
address myself briefly to the audience here
in the hall too  Also to you in the online
stream, collect questions, we'll
get to
the Q&A part in a few minutes and then you can
of course also address them to the podium yes,
status of research, recommendations from
research for the best possible
orientation of cities,
yes than that  you can manage this balance well between
biodiversity human needs
instead of alignment ask
again openly yes please so
maybe if you look at it on a
larger scale the first
surprising finding is that
biodiversity has increased in cities
there are three reasons for this
Now if I
describe these examples, maybe in
Dubai
in 1950 there was only natural
vegetation there, so practically all the
vegetation that was there in Dubai
was of course on site then they
built and of course pushed the natural
vegetation to the edge or something like that
Some of certain species were no longer
present, it was a process that
happened more slowly than the people who
moved in and planted their gardens with
non-native plants or invasive
plants. This meant that
biodiversity increased in most cities
and the imagination we ourselves have  have
from nature and that is now in
research there are actually three
concepts that we think about namely
what is the nature of nature
i.e. if you left it completely to its own devices
what would it look like
the problem is that we cannot
imagine  Because we have two other
concepts - human nature -
think of our design
of our gardens or parks -
we imagine how nature
could be designed and the nature
we would like to have, we would like it to be close to
nature and these three concepts
determine  Today we actually
walk around in cities and
think about how we would
actually like nature to be and this last
concept is very important because we
all imagine that nature
should actually be as natural as possible and we have
recently been planting roofs with as diverse a variety as possible
Plants
now have the effect that
helps us increase biodiversity in
cities. We are all
exposed to climate change and
climate change means that we increase the
range of possible plants that
grow in a city. I will give
you an example in the city  In Zurich,
the number of frost days has decreased
by a factor of 5 in the last 40 years,
so it is possible that you
can now plant palm trees in sheltered locations in the city of Zurich that
actually overwinter
or that you can see them in gardens, especially
in people who have larger gardens  They
protect the light as a
garden fence. They all know each other: the
cherry laurel. The cherry laurel is
a very popular plant because it
has very dense, light-tight leaves. You ca
n't see through it. It's a non-
native plant in Zurich
These are
all effects of biodiversity that
have increased biodiversity for the benefit
of what we think how
we would like to see nature and
today we increasingly have to expect
that we can value nature in
some form and the best form is
probably  always
included in a monetary basis, so how can we estimate
the value of nature today, what is it worth
that I have a garden bed and plant it with
various plants,
what can this show and
the interesting thing is if you
look at how much legislation there is
includes the value of nature, then today that is still
extremely rare or completely absent, so
I think we have to
make huge progress there so that we include the
value of nature in our considerations
if we
turn from that to the IPC and the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate Change perspective like that  a little bit
more development climate change with an
eye on also the question of
professional combinations how should a city be
optimally aligned what is the
state of research from your point of view
am ready
where we see you ipcces that major city
what you works is really  always thing
about
solutions possible
diversity and this good forest so we
will we can answer yesterdistry question
then we know when on Drive Stories also
no diversity
building turn rather than small steps
also longer term planning
measurement evidence-based decisions
and that's good if we
can tick all the boxes  It's good for the climate,
it's good for urban development, for
people, for the biosphere but
trade offs, that's what it means in German, so to speak,
the conflicts that remain, the
compromises that have to be made. Ms.
Jasper, there is a case from Berlin where
They say it can't be solved optimally,
but that's the best way, perhaps
to give a positive message,
perhaps first to name a best practice
case or best practice cases,
which are now also
being researched internationally and receive prizes,
for example the South Terrain Nature Park, for example the
Pack am Gleisdreieck  Tempelhofer
Feld is a city from below initiative
where nature conservation and
recreational use have come together, so to speak,
so there are a lot of positive
examples but of course there are
now Berlin,
as we know, is still
relatively relaxed compared to other cities, perhaps as a
city but Berlin is a growing
city  There is a lot of pressure to build, there
are many different crises
such as the housing crisis that we
have to deal with and there are of course
areas of conflict and many of these very
biodiversity places like undeveloped areas for
example or
water protection zones and they are under
ever increasing pressure and there has to be  There are,
so to speak, solutions that
work both socially and ecologically
and that is a big challenge,
thank you very much. Now let's pin this
down specifically to the cities and urban development plans and
then I'll come back to you, my Ms.
Schendler, Ms. Gnes, we have  I also
brought a few pictures with me here from Zurich,
what measures are you currently implementing?
What new findings are resulting
from the measures and if you
would like to comment on the pictures, thank you very much, so
what you see there is
actually the heat distribution in
the  In the city of Zurich, the heat zones are what
we also heard earlier. The city center
gets hotter and cools down. The
difference from the city center to the outskirts of the
city is green, which
is perhaps just under 80 meters high, which can be up to ten
degrees in really hot weather
Summer days but I think the key word
is planning in this context. In addition to
the interesting idea that
nature should also have a price,
we also try planning.
This is a municipal
settlement plan and is called Löber,
settlement, landscapes, public buildings
and of course it is also a city
Unlike Berlin, we no longer have any
reserves in our inventory, so we do
n't have any soil reserves in our inventory. How do we really grow
in our inventory and at the same time we have
checked that with growth
there is also a need for more green spaces, which
you can't see on this map now, but
that's an attempt, for example
We tried to create a whole network of
green spaces across the city in
which the large existing parks
were connected with all the small
private ones.
Yes, you can't see it here either, but these
are the dense areas, the
pink areas, these are the areas
in which  can be densified the most
in the near future, so we are
still waiting for growth of about 25%
of the population by 2040, which is a lot
for Zurich, but someone sees a
bit of green space and
this network was laid over this entire city, also with
the claim that
On the one hand, the connecting paths between them get a quality of stay
and on the other hand they become important for
heat reduction for biodiversity
and for greening
and then there is perhaps
a second example of my
biodiversity strategy also formulated in
connection with this with this
planning  The implementation of
the measures is still at the very beginning,
but there is an example in there that there is
supposed to be advice for
owners of the gardens, the large
and the small gardens, like every man
and every woman actually has his or her
garden, no matter how big  how smaller
is it biodiverse or more biodiverse
can plant and use two
examples thank you very much with a pivot to
Berlin questions that we
really want to show that not only
visions but also really concrete
measures are implemented that give you
hope maybe
you can point to some examples  from
Berlin, so first of all the
big thing is that here in Berlin,
together with the Senate for
Environmental Mobility and Climate Protection, we have
founded the rainwater agency and
within the framework of the rainwater agency
we give advice, so this knowledge, which we are
currently discussing very intensively here, is given to
planning citizens  and also to another
deck or further and that then leads to
here we see the example of the
school grounds. Until recently it was
a completely normal asphalt yard
and they deliberately
disconnected it here, so they kept rainwater on the
area, they laid out greenery
and that's how it is  The
feeling of being at home for the children during the
break is much better, you have
complete management here, so there
is no more rainwater runoff and that is not
in the outside area but rather
directly with Prenzlauer Berg, so that
means you can do a lot even on a small scale,
perhaps in a very short time  Many people still do
n't know it when they
park their cars somewhere on this parking ban,
maintenance is still carried out there
and a system is destroyed, which
is also a so-called rainwater trough, which is
actually supposed to ensure that the
water is kept directly on site even in these streets that are not very
busy
Berlin
has not only stone in the subsoil
but also a very sandy
subsoil, which means that the rainwater
seeps away here and is
kept as a treasure, so to speak.
So it is very important that when you see
prohibition signs here, the hollow is now
relatively deep
there  You wouldn't necessarily
drive in now, but you often have it on the
side of the road and you can only
appeal that you don't park there.
Yes, we are also very active here and
we say how can you
develop neighborhoods instead, so there have to be
a lot of them  Departments
think together because a lot
is done quickly, it has already been discussed to what extent do
you have mosquitoes that then cause
any dangerous illnesses, so
when you start talking to the
citizens,
negative points are also mentioned very quickly, yes, that, for
my sake, areas have to be set up
if we are here now  There is an open area of
water in Copenhagen when you
walk, there are also a lot of paths and
gullies and deep ditches and I asked
you people do
n't fall in and then the answer was, well,
everyone can swim here, so
we still have to learn here
To use rooms multifunctionally, yes, we also have to
learn to have trust in ourselves, to
say that when we are out there we
usually sit by the water, yes, it is
much more chill and no matter what we
do, diplomats like to drink,
which is often in open water areas
and  This unsealing is beneficial so that
the water is returned
to the substrate and available for our
use again. My
favorite saying is water is not
used, yes we have to think about
what substances we put in there, yes
that is important but otherwise
we should create solutions like this  It's
shown here, snacks, that's
exactly what has already been mentioned.
Development of Tegel Airport. There are
n't many cities that have such large areas.
I would really like to
put one thing right:
the water protection areas are non-
negotiable.
Berlin has 25% of the city's area as a
water protection area because we are from  of
our own resource life and in the
Tegel area above we have the
Tegel waterworks and we are in the process of
developing urban quarters there and
that is a look into the
Kurt Schumacher quarter and there
they really want to integrate blue-green infrastructure from
the start, think about water and
I  I think these are situations where
you look in and say I feel
more comfortable there than with some of the
government buildings that were newly built
in Berlin where the entire forecourt
is still sealed, so that makes us
look forward to the future of our cities. Thank you very much now  It's
your turn if you want with
your questions and you already
told me in the online stream a very short
question I would shoot over to you
Mr. Schneider Mr. Schreibmann
we showed these remote sensing images at the
beginning of the two cities
seen next to each other. Very short
thought  how Berlin and Zurich
can also act as
roll models or as
experimental laboratories, if you like,
you can write if you would like to comment
on it. I think if we
want to do persuasion,
remote sensing images help a lot because they
awaken people's emotions.
You certainly have them  You may have already caught yourself
looking on Google Maps at
what your
garden, your house, the surrounding area looks like on a satellite image,
which means we can arouse
emotions very strongly using this imagery
and if we can then convey the
biodiversity message with these
images then
I think  that a lot of people
understand why this is so important, that
in a spatial context you
understand what biodiversity means in the
context of a city. I would like to
give a very short example. It's
about so-called social narratives
that connect people and nature, imagine
very quickly  you
get a picture that you
give to someone to pass on your expression of
biodiversity if you
think quickly about it, what kind of
picture would you choose then
I would now speculate that
most people would take a flower meadow with a
lot of different types of flowers
now the flower meadows are not  the
most diverse
biodiversity areas in the world
namely the tropical rainforests but
with our cultural background we
would probably rather than people from Zurich
or Berlin pass on a picture of a
tropical rainforest
what is even more unimaginable is that
in this picture maybe five people are
having a picnic on this meadow
is again cultural so that
biodiversity and you can
also ask your friends about it.
Biodiversity in our language does
not include people.
In Japan it is unthinkable that they
talk about biodiversity without
also depicting people,
that is, I think  We need a lot
more narrative ones that explain and
you could see that very well in the example of ask Niers
from Tegel Airport
where the integration of nature and people
takes place at the same time and you can visualize that
wonderfully with satellite images.
Schneider has another thought
on that  at Humboldt
University, for example, the integrated
research institute for human-
environmental relations as an important
interdisciplinary unit. I would also
think that it is important not to think in
terms of people and the environment but in
terms of the environment
and, above all, I would
like to interject that the city does not
is a detached part of the landscape
but that the city basically focuses on
the energy and mass flows that
are in a landscape structure, i.e. the determining
city and its surrounding area and then there are
also the intercontinental references,
i.e. the avocado that I buy here, be it
there  No matter how beautiful the organic shop is, it has
a journey behind it, it has virtual
water in it, it
uses energy during transport
etc. and in the cities we have
a lot of committed people together
and if they pay attention to what
material and energy flows they
are traveling with  and how they deal with what they
find on site instead of the environment and the surrounding world
is of course also an
example and a political impulse that goes
beyond the city because the
city is also where the political power
is centered due to the many people
in a small space  plays in the national and
global space and when we
talk about 1.5 degrees of warming worldwide,
we are talking about three degrees of warming over the land areas
and the mountains probably
more like three and a half to four degrees if
we
are traveling as we are at the moment  If you allow two to
two and a half or, in the worst case,
three degrees globally, then a
city like Berlin will be five to six degrees
warmer and in the Swiss foothills or in
the Alps it will be more like seven degrees
warmer. You can't imagine a world like that,
I can't imagine it either
imagine and I don't want
my grandchildren to grow up in a world like that
and that's why
we need political impulse
in the cities where the political power
is centered to
turn things around so there is a very clear
connection between the commitment of
individual people in the  City and
what political clout we
bring to the ground for the change that
we now need for the change that we
need now, thank you very much for the strong
call, now it's your turn again,
you've waited long enough with your
questions, we'll do it  So please hold
up a sign with the
question marks on it if you have one,
otherwise just shake your hand,
briefly say your name and then please answer the
question in very brief form because we
have very little time and
I have Andreas Linzbauer here for the online audience
who can ask me questions,
we'll ask briefly or we'll bring
a quick question from the room
if there is one here, yes, there's a microphone at the front.
Hello, thank you very much for the contributions. We
've heard relatively little specifically about water
shortages in Zurich and Berlin
and I  I would like to ask you
to what extent this is an issue, especially when
we are
talking about 1,522.5 degrees in the future and
what measures will be taken for this,
thank you very much for the extremely important question
and I will also give a short answer here.
Great, yes I can talk about that very quickly  There
was a lot of scarcity in order to perhaps
avoid the solution finally digital [music] yes, that's why this is really
a situation that is presented in the city and country here.
We have the rivers, we have heard that the
flow spray Havel is
significantly reduced in the summer, which means
we are moving the infiltration into the
Overall, the
environmental research center still
shows that the infiltration, i.e.
the groundwater recharge in
Germany, is stable in the winter months. Yes, that depends
Let us have further
questions, let other perspectives be heard.
First of all, thank you for the question and for the answers.
There will be an
opportunity for exchange outside in the forum. In
a few minutes, a question from the
online area Andreas. Yes, that
just follows on from here. How does Berlin react?  if
the Spree gets too little water from
open-cast lignite mining or if
Mecklenburg-Western Pomerania allows less water to
flow to Berlin Brandenburg that is
again divided into water grenades so
Berlin is I am also on the strategy
council of the international water
association a watermy city because
it is already in
started in the early years
to keep their groundwater level constant, yes that
's it, you can watch the video
drinks like drinkwave drink wave from
balls and the YouTube where you can see that
you really don't use the water
but use it like we are
now building in our sewage treatment plant  beautiful
linden tree, the greatest possible
removal of trace substances, which means that
the water quality is increased to such an extent
that this
water that has seeped through the subsoil is then
available again as a groundwater resource.
This is very sustainable.
We are really a roll model worldwide here
like in the one on the indirect
portable water reviews, that's a
lot of research work, a lot of knowledge
from the Berlin universities and
institutes that flowed into it and
was certainly
politically triggered
the world has no and
I emphasize no water shortage, the
world has no water shortage because we do
not lose any water molecules,
that is, the water molecules that the
world gains through meteorites are
negligible, those that we
lose through tectonic
actions are also negligible,
but what we do is through
reconfiguration  In the landscape
we shift precipitation regimes
for different water
availability and because we have
shifted this it may be that there
is too little water in certain places but
again the total amount of water
worldwide remains constant in physical
units so it is
very important that you in this
Pay attention to terminology and say which
technical methods Gio Engineering
can we use to redistribute the water in such a way
that it
can be used multiple times and can reduce the
shortages in the places where it is
actually needed,
so for me that is always very
important, it sounds like a
Horrible scenario that in 5000 years there will be
no more water on the earth. This
scenario does not exist today.
Now I am so sorry that we
probably won't
be able to answer all the questions. Today we
will record one more from the room and
answer it properly, but I would
Then they go away to the aperitif and then
really tackle the bum lists again
with all their other questions
and maybe comments and
feedback. Next time we'll just have to
bring a lot more time with us for the conversation. I'll raise a question
again  The hand is all
good, so now perhaps a bit
contradictory to the previous answers.
Of course, internationally,
water scarcity is a huge issue if
you look at the Sahel zone and so on.
The question is also how we manage this politically. Is there
or must be privatization of the water trade?  that is to be
secured as a public good, there
are tendencies that Nestlé and the large
food companies are becoming
very involved here. Are there
any efforts in the international context
to define water as a public good, so to speak, and how do
local politicians view the use
of water as a consumer good or as  As a
true, so to speak, she gives answers from the panel
I briefly divide the question into
the international
perspective, are there movements
efforts and then the local
perspective who would like a
short comment on the fact that
freshwater reserves are one of the dozen
global boundaries that are
related to  the socio-ecological
transformation in action which
plays a role in 100 we actually have
biodiversity and climate crisis in the
spotlight here and the biodiversity crisis is
currently the most dangerous of all the
global borders that
humanity has to deal with. The climate crisis is
also one that is perhaps only on
Third or fourth place and the crisis of
fresh water reserves, no
water is lost globally, but I have to have the water
where I have agriculture
and where I have people who
need it and these
distribution conflicts or Michael
that then leads beyond the regional to
global and  international
conflicts and many parts of the world
with cross-border rivers and
dam construction, we can also prove this with an
example and these are
challenges that we also
have to solve internationally. This is a
global question and a global crisis, the
freshwater crisis Ms. Schindler at the
local level, so we are  of course
not those at the local level who
can regulate but water, yes, what is a
public good and so
this protected one with levels
of course became the lake from the
80s when nobody actually
wanted to drink from it where it was treated
and the whole population  be it brought
along provided there
are
regulations at the cantonal level that
really protect the lake and the banks
and in that sense yes it is a
public good it is not a commodity and not
yet a commodity I actually hope
that we do not develop there
the water trade
yes that very briefly yes
Berlin was privatized Berlin was
communalized again as a grassroots movement
and that's a good thing
that's a nice final word
basically although it's not quite over yet
my own final remarks after
observing and moderating this
fan again up here  to come back
this is of course a simple picture at
first simple narrative introduction to
talk about the water everything
we heard about today it is of course
highly complex different dynamics that
also extend over time into the
future many really
dramatic challenges that lie
ahead of us many
hopeful action scenarios  which
we are already seeing in the implementation of such
a panel so that it can be managed very closely
and made very simply is of course
simply not possible, that the
beauty of science is that
many complexities can exist side by side
and yet perhaps it is
that simple  I wanted to
ask something again at the end, which
really boils down to actions on us
as citizens
and that as a very last
final sprint in order to make concrete calls here again
and perhaps the question to
all of you again in one sentence
just what is your
most relevant tip your most important
recommendation your call to action how we
as individuals can have a positive impact on this
water biodiversity triangle
and then I'll start
with you Ms. Gnas yes in Berlin there
is a nice project that
protects the neighborhood  the street trees
take care of you green and that is my
final word wonderful
commitment I think create awareness of
how valuable water is forest green on
all levels be it strategic at the
universities among personal
circles of friends simply create awareness thank you
my advice would be to put pressure on politics
I would like to  Take two answers together
when citizens get
involved, for example for their
tree slice or for whatever then
creates the emotions and social
cohesion that then creates the political
pressure for the change that we
need because the big solutions for
adapting to climate change and
biodiversity crisis must
be political solutions we can't
leave individual people alone with it, thank you
very much I'll say something else that can be used for
entertainment with the following
aperoids. I don't say it in
my words but in the words of
Josef Stiglitz, the Nobel Prize winner, it
's about money and he has it  The
assumption that there is an infinitely long
living creature basically
assumes that we will compensate future
generations free of charge for
biodiversity climate and environmental damage
and if we don't
change that, namely this free
compensation, we will have no chance
of achieving anything, that is what
I think the
argument is  I think it's very important that you can also
look at this from a financial point of view.
Thank you very much. That was
another excellent final word. Now
I would also like to thank you in the audience
who
moved out of the house on this Saturday morning for this science
Complexities followed us, I hope
you gained some insight, you
were able to take some good information with you
to our viewers in the
online stream, and many thanks to you.
We have now collected the questions, so
perhaps we can
do something else afterwards. I would like to thank you in
particular  the two
institutes that brought us
together here, the
Humboldt University of Berlin and the
University of Zurich,
especially the people who were
very involved in the preparation
and I would like to
highlight just a few Marcel Schneider
Uta Sommer Andreas linzbauer Britta
Schumacher Britta Schumacher  and
of course the whole thing about the Science
weak team, I think it
's worth a round of applause, thank you very much
then a big thank you to our
two opening speakers, Mr. Vogel
had to get on his way again,
Mr. Seeger, thank you very much
for being here, that was  an
honor, a pleasure and applause to you too
and last but not least a thank you to
our fantastic panel I think
it was wonderful how these different
perspectives came together,
I thank you all and a
big applause again to you
[applause]
last  organizational information there is
another yes, thank you, my name is Felix
Runde I was pleased
last organizational information there is
a warm invitation again
from the University of Zurich and the
Humboldt University to the
Aperol network now yes, it takes place here,
take your questions with you  your
comments with this evening there is another
chance to meet the partners here
at a dialogue event in Zurich
Berlin at 6 p.m. also here on site and
then I wish you a nice
lunch afternoon and continued good
conversations, thank you
[applause]